we have three hundred thousand alumni
currently and they're all over the world
as you talk to alumni about what they're
finding to connect to through the CAA it
is a lifelong relationship it's
important the further outside of New
York City that those connections happen
and that's what the CAA provides we have
Miami Art Basel where we connect
Colombians in the southern Florida
region we came i would say ambassadors
and major sponsor of our puzzle we felt
that the caliber of the fair and what it
stood for would open up many
opportunities everyone in this region
these paintings kind of they definitely
came out of a lot of work I was doing at
school that was that's what I started
doing a Columbia education is really
great it keeps expanding after you
experience it
we have curated tours with art faculty
and the Dean of the School of the Arts
Carol Becker
friends of mine have come to art basel
in miami and i always felt left out you
come to a big event like that you need
somebody to guide you and tell you
what's worth seeing and what isn't the
columbia alumni association provided
that and then I give Columbia credit
it's a very intellectual crowd and
sophisticated crowd that comes in here
for this one week but many of those
people are seeing this art for the first
time and we're all learning from that
shared experience we're going to have
250 to 300 people here and everyone's
excited and they love it it makes it
worthwhile we get a lot of people that
move down here more and more announce on
ham new to the area and we're starting
to connect those people
and then you realize you're doing
something good for people
like Network events it tends to feed
upon itself you get a bigger and more
noticed Art Basel event which leads to
other events
there's been a tremendous organization
growth of the columbia alumni
association in south florida and and so
miami is blossoming